madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les
députés je ne veux pas m'apesantir sur
une situation qui n'a pas changé et que
chacun
connaît notre pays a besoin d'un budget
et les oppositions ne souhaitent pas
trouver de compromis avec nous pour
l'adopter malgré cela s'il vous plaît
madame Chikirou malgré
cela allez s'il vous plaît madame la
premierère ministre à la
parole ça ne do pas être long je vous
rassure c'est comme ça malgré cela nous
n'avons pas renoncer au dialogue ce
texte a été enrichi par des amendements
de la majorité comme des oppositions à
l'Assemblée nationale comme au Sénat je
pense notamment dans cette première
partie à la réforme des zones de
revitalisation rurale adopté au Sénat
une réforme qui va permettre d'y inclure
4000 communes de plus que prévu
initialement mais alors que les délais
constitutionnels mais alors que les
délais
constitutionnels allez mais alors que
les délais constitutionnel nous presse
et qu'aucun groupe d'opposition n'est
prêt à voter ce budget nous devons
prendre nos respons
nous ne pouvons pas priver nos services
publics de leurs moyens nous ne pouvons
pas priver notre sécurité notre justice
et nos armées de hausse inédite de leur
budget nous ne pouvons pas priver la
transition écologique de moyens sans
précédent nous ne pouvons pas priver nos
enseignants d'une augmentation de leur
salaire de 125 € minimum par mois aussi
sur le fondement de l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la première partie du projet de loit de
finance pour 2024 je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre
l'Assemblée nationale prend acte de
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement conformément aux
dispositions de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution le texte sur lequel la
première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
inséré en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa 1er du règlement le
débat sur ce texte est immédi suspendu
ce texte sera considéré comme adopté
sauf si une motion de censure déposée
avant demain 15h35 et voté dans les
conditions prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution la Conférence des
présidents se réunira aujourd'hui à
15h45 pour fixer la date et les
modalités de discussion d'une éventuelle
motion de censure la séance est
levée